>> Greg: "USA TODAY" SURVEY
CLAIMS AMERICANS FACE THE NEXT
ELECTION WITH A DOMINANT SENSE
OF DREAD.
APPARENTLY THE CANDIDATE OF
WATER SUPPORTS LOSES, THEN
ROUGHLY 40% OF THOSE VOTERS
WOULDN’T BE CONFIDENT THAT THE
ELECTION WAS ACTUALLY FAIR.
MANY OF THE ELECTION MAY BE OVER
ON THAT FIRST TUESDAY IN
NOVEMBER BUT COME WEDNESDAY, THE
DEBATE OVER ITS LEGITIMACY
BEGINS.
WHO’S FAULT IS THAT?
THE MEDIA.
THEY SPENT THREE YEARS CHASING
THE FLAME OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION
ONLY TO TURN UP WITH EMPTY,
CHARRED HANDS.
YOU THINK THAT DIDN’T MESS WITH
AMERICA’S MIND?
CNN AND EMBED BC DID MORE THAT
ARE HER MINOR ELECTION SYSTEM
THEN THE RUSSIAN SIMILE BY
EXAGGERATING THE NARRATIVE IN
ORDER TO INCITE THE ORANGE
MONSTER THEY DESPISE.
PUTIN MUST BE THINKING ABOUT THE
UPSIDE OF A FREE PRESS.
LOOK WHAT IT DID FOR HIM IN
AMERICA.
HE ACHIEVED MORE THAN A FARM OF
RUSSIAN BOTS SPENDING 100 GRAND
ON FACEBOOK ADS EVER COULD.
THAT STORY COLLAPSED ON THE
OBSESSED MEDIA ARE STILL SEEING
RUSSIANS IN THEIR SLEEP.
THE MEDIA, OUT OF BITTERNESS
OVER DEFEAT, THEY COULD NOT MOVE
FAST AND LEFT US WITH A COUNTRY
QUESTIONING WHETHER ANY ELECTION
COULD BE LEGITIMATE.
NOT BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS MIGHT
COLLUDE WITH TRUMP BECAUSE THE
MEDIA ALWAYS COLLUDES WITH THE
DAMS.
EMILY
, CAN YOU BLAME AMERICANS
SERVING SKEPTICAL.
>> Emily: I AGREE, IT MAKES
SENSE.
MOST VOTERS VIEW IT AS A CIVIL
WAR AND THE RESULTS ARE GOING TO
BE CATASTROPHIC IF THEIR SIDE
LOSES WHICH IS PERPETUATED BY
THE MEDIA AND ALSO I THINK
THERE’S A MEASURE OF FATIGUE.
THE FIRST DEMOCRATIC DEBATE WAS
HELD IN JUNE, 16 MONTHS BEFORE
THE ELECTION AND THAT’S
LITERALLY AN ELEPHANT PREGNANCY.
>> Greg: IS IT REALLY?
I’M GLAD YOU LOOK THAT UP.
IT IS AN ELEPHANT’S PREGNANCY.
THINGS.
THAT’S A WAY TO MEASURE A LOT OF
WE WANT TO MORTGAGE, WHAT’S HE
GOING TO?
FOUR ELEPHANT PREGNANCIES.
JUAN, WHEN TRUMP WINS THE
ELECTION BY A LANDSLIDE, WILL WE
BE ABLE TO HAVE A CONGENIAL
SHOW?
>> Juan: YES, BECAUSE I’LL BE
GONE.
[LAUGHTER]
I WILL HAVE BURIED MYSELF.
DO I GET A FREE PASS TO CANADA?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Juan: I THINK THIS --
PEOPLE ANTICIPATED IT’S GOING TO
BE A DIRTY ELECTION BECAUSE
TRUMP NEEDS TO DIRTY UP
DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL BE FINE.
IT’S A LOT OF NASTINESS.
THE SECOND THING IS I THINK THIS
POLL IS NOT GOOD NEWS FOR TRUMP.
PEOPLE ARE SO HIGHLY ENGAGED.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION
RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE HAVE STRONG FEELINGS
>> Greg: YOU AGREE THAT TRUMP
HAS MADE AMERICA SMARTER.
>> Juan: WERE POLITICAL
BECAUSE THINGS WERE SO
POLARIZED.
I THINK YOU GET TIRED OF THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE SO UPSET
DAILY ABOUT TRUMP’S BEHAVIOR AND
TWEETS.
>> Greg: I SAY THIS TO MY
DRIVER EVERY NIGHT.
>> Juan: I MUST BE DRIVING.
HILLARY CLINTON, EMILY,
HILLARY CLINTON ACCEPTED THE
RESULTS, THE PERSON WHO SAID I
DON’T KNOW IF I WILL ACCEPT THE
RESULTS, THAT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: JASON, JUAN TALKS
ABOUT A DIRTY CAMPAIGN BUT HOW
CAN YOU GET DIRTIER THAN IT IS
ALREADY WHEN YOU SAY TRUMP IS
WORSE THAN HITLER, MAO, STALIN.
WHERE’D YOU GO?
>> Juan: I HAVE AN IDEA.
THE DEVIL.
>> Greg: THE DEVIL,
ANTICHRIST.
WE CAN PUT THEM TOGETHER.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE DEEP STATE.
YOU’RE TAKING THEM ALL.
>> Jason: DEEP DISH.
>> Greg: DOUBLED THE DISH.
>> Jason: WAIT TILL HE GETS
SPACE COMMAND UP AND RUNNING.
>> Juan: OH, NO.
YOU DIDN’T TELL ME, JASON.
>> Jason: THEY HAVE A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THESE THINGS ARE WAY TOO LONG.
IT’S AUGUST.
WE HAVE UNTIL NEXT AUGUST BEFORE
THE CAMPAIGN REALLY STARTS TO
RAMP UP.
I DO THINK THERE’S A GREAT
DISSERVICE, A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT TO FELT LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS REALLY GOT TAKEN
TO THE CLEANERS.
HE HAD THE ENERGY AND 2016, HE
WAS TAKEN OUT OF THE PROCESS.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW DISENGAGING A
LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVE THEY ARE
DEALING WITH THE DEBATE.
HERE’S OUR TOP, AND HERE’S THE
REST.
THEY ARE SELF ELIMINATING A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND NOW THEY HAVE ALL
THESE CANDIDATES SAYING THIS
ISN’T FAIR.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
TULSI GABBARD WHO HAVE A REAL
MESSAGE THAT MAY NOT MAKE THE
THRESHOLD.
I THINK IT’S DISENGAGING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Greg: TO JASON’S POINT,
THREE PEOPLE.
TULSI GABBARD.
MARYANNE.
>> Dana: IF YOU ARE NOT AT 2%
-- EVERYONE KNEW WHAT THE RULES
WERE.
THEY MIGHT DISAGREE WITH THE
RULES BUT ONE OF THE REASONS,
WHY DO THEY HAVE THESE RULES?
BERNIE SANDERS.
HE COMPLAINED THE SYSTEM IS
RIGGED AGAINST HIM SO NOW IT’S
MORE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT AND IF
YOU ARE POLLING AT TWO IN THE
SEPTEMBER 23 WEEKS BEFORE THE
FIRST VOTE IN IOWA, YOU’RE
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT UNLESS SOMETHING
CATASTROPHIC HAPPENS ON THESE
POLL NUMBERS ARE HAPPENING
BEFORE THE ONSLAUGHT OF ADS.
IMAGINE IF YOU’RE IN AN EARLY
BATTLEGROUND STATE LIKE IOWA,
THINK IT’S ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY ARE ALREADY SEEING ADS TO I
THESE NUMBERS NEED TO BE LIKE
THIS BECAUSE OF YOU HAD TO DEAL
WITH THAT ALL THE TIME, SEE IT
IN YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA FEED.
>> Jason: NOBODY IS AT 30%.
>> Dana: YOU THINK
TULSI GABBARD COULD WIN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION?
SHE’S BEEN RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
FOR EIGHT MONTHS.
>> Greg: SHE COULD EVENT A
VPP.
>> Dana: SHE COULD STILL BE A
DP POSSIBILITY.
>> Jason: THE REPUBLICANS, 18
DIFFERENT DEBATES.
WE HAVE A LOT TO LOOK AT.
DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: THEY ARE SELF
NARROWING.
THEY DON’T HAVE MONEY LEFT.
>> Greg: I DON’T THINK THE
MEDIA IS GOING TO BELIEVE IF
TRUMP WINS.
>> Juan: ONE LAST POINT, WITH